[Music]
[Applause]
hi my name is mayakovsky I'm a product
manager in security and privacy at
Google focused on encryption today we'll
be talking about encryption in transit
how Google encrypts data by defaults to
and within our infrastructure when you
send a request to a Google cloud service
like Google Cloud Storage or Gmail that
request is first routed via globally
distributed system called the Google
front end the Google front end encrypts
traffic from user to Google and provides
load balancing and DDoS attack
prevention the Google front end protects
your data using authentication which
verifies the source of your data
integrity which makes sure the data that
you send arrives at its destination
unaltered and encryption which makes
sure that your data is private any data
that you send to a Google cloud service
is encrypted in transit by default from
the user to the Google front end using
transport layer security this protection
is implemented using boring SSL which is
an open-source implementation of the TLS
protocol the users browser will
automatically negotiate the highest
version of the protocol for
communication with Google to ensure the
best possible security so if once your
data is inside Google what happens first
it's important to understand that not
all data in transit inside Google is
protected the same way we apply
different protections to data in transit
depending on whether or not it's
transmitted outside a physical boundary
controlled by Google when data exits a
physical boundary controlled by Google
we assume that the network can only be
some I trusted and that data needs
further protection on the other hand
when data stays within our physical
boundaries we have rigorous security
measures in place within our
infrastructure which serves to secure
that link let's talk about encryption at
the network layer or layer 3 Google
clouds virtual network infrastructure
encrypts the VM to VM traffic if it
crosses a physical boundary not
controlled by Google the communicating
hosts perform a handshake and then
encrypt data using AES 128 all data in
transit layer 3 whether or not it leaves
a physical boundary is authenticated
this protects a compromised host from
spoofing packets on the network
next we encrypt at the application layer
or layer 7 Google's infrastructure
provides authentication integrity and
encryption of remote procedure calls
from service to service when those calls
leave a physical boundary controlled by
Google this is also a handshake protocol
and data is encrypted using any
1:28 within a physical boundary
controlled by Google these remote
procedure calls are still protected with
both authentication and integrity so to
sum up our story Google uses multiple
layers of security to protect your data
in transit including authentication
integrity and encryption we encrypt and
authenticate data in transit at one or
more network layers when that data moves
outside physical boundaries not
controlled by Google data in transit
inside a physical boundary controlled by
Google is authenticated but not
necessarily encrypted because rigorous
physical security measures are in place
by default to learn more read our web
paper
encryption and transit in Google Cloud
[Music]
[Applause]
you